[Musique]
monsieur vous êtes souvent arrêtés par
des auto stoppeurs sharif sur manqué à
nassau voire de la route surtout en
période des vacances est ce que vous
vous arrêtez non pas tellement parce que
les patrons ne sont pas assurés d'avoir
pour ça et puis on risque plutôt d'avoir
des embêtements si ça nous arrive un
accident
monsieur amené vous des auto stoppeurs
quelquefois non jamais pourquoi parce
que on risque beaucoup d'accidents et
depuis c'est un principe chaque année on
le transporte monsieur vous ne prenez
pas d'auto stop
non monsieur pourquoi premièrement parce
que ce qui est interdit par la maison va
au culot travailler
premièrement par notre patron et de
gimont c'est quand même une
responsabilité pour nous quoi on vous a
donné des instructions précises
interdisant d'embarquer les
auto-stoppeurs eu assez sérieux véhicule
on allait
les pancartes ou sous peine de renvoi
immédiat il est formellement interdit
d'effectuer avec son véhicule tout
transport de personnel marchandises
étrangères longer une plongée avis
malgré l'obligeance des routiers les
auto-stoppeurs ne sont jamais certain de
trouver une voiture qui aille où ils
veulent et qu'ils partent quand ils
veulent pour être certain de partir les
étudiants peuvent s'adresser à un
organisme d'auto-stop permanent madame
valter vous dirigez l'auto-stop
permanent qui s'appelle pro bahia est ce
que ça veut dire pro bayard pro voyage
c'est une association d'étudiants qui
est spécialisée dans la mise en relation
de passagers qui désirent voyager et qui
participe aux frais d'essence avec les
automobilistes peuvent sembler et le nom
même de brevets nord que signifie et
bien c'est en même temps le numéro de
téléphone on peut former sur le cadran
toutes les lettres pont ouailles à
désirer j'aurais pu partir avignon aux
environs du 25 juillet
vous êtes une passagère passagère c'est
la première fois que vous venez ici à
prendre vous savez comment cela se passe
nous avait une cotisation ici qui est de
5 20 ces petits nation est valable pour
une année ou deux voyages
alors ensuite vous arranger avec
l'automobiliste pour la participation
aux frais 10 ans qui peut vous demander
de la patience en principe une moyenne
de 3,4 centimes par kilomètre alors vous
voulez je vous inscrire oui bien sûr bon
mademoiselle pourquoi vous êtes vous
adresser à pro variable à dubaï a
vraiment décide d'en je suis allé passer
maison à l'économique sienne et j'ai vu
une affiche et j'ai trouvé sorte comme
mode de voyage économie c'est pour faire
des économies sur vos vacances
très certainement est ce que ça ne nous
inquiète pas un petit peu de montées
avec un automobiliste que vous ne
connaîtrez pas de faire des kilomètres
avec lui jusqu'ici j'ai pratiqué assez
souvent
interdit en france que l'auto stop et
sans trop d'ennuis
c'est pourquoi vous aimez ça l'auto stop
où vous le fait parce que vous ne pouvez
pas faire autrement
d'une part il ya vraiment des raisons et
d'autres pas un intérêt tout simplement
humain parce qu'on traversant les
régions il m'arrivait d'être prises en
part d auto club de bien connaître les
problèmes par exemple particulier à la
main d'oeuvre on discute dans laquelle
mgr qui me demandait vert je ne sais pas
vers ce lieu par exemple où la vé lusine
et ça m'a permis d'avoir une
connaissance humaine des régions avec
les routiers aussi j'ai pu connaître un
haut lieu de paniquer vous avez beaucoup
voyagé avec les routiers eu très peu aux
étages et surtout faire d'abord pourrait
résoudre de construire en commun
c'était très amusant on ajouté dans un
gros camion nous lie mais l'assistant
tout ce trajet est long le confort qui
vous a fait venir à propos minky départ
est de pouvoir choisir une voiture
américaine
qu'importe la voiture l'essentiel est
d'arriver je dirais à l'endroit ça ne
vous ennuie pas un petit peu de laisser
tomber un peu le côté aventureux de
l'auto-stop
en venant ici non ça je crois que les
enfants chercher le risque pour le
plaisir du risque c'est un fait on
minimum de sécurité c'est déjà ça
[Musique]